[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم على وقع معارك
واشتباكات وصلت الى وسط طرابلس تواصل
اطراف الازمه الليبيه محادثات مطوله في
مدينه السخيرات المغربيه بحثا عن صيغه
ترضي الجميع حول قضايا متشابكه تحدد
مؤسسات المرحله الانتقاليه الرئاسه
الحكومه الوطنيه الدستور وايضا السلطه
التشريعيه نتوقف مع هذا الموضوع لنناقش في
محورين هل دخل الحوار الليبي مرحله الحسم
وما هي فرص التوصل الى
حل وما هو مغزى استمرار المعارك في ظل
التفاوض وكيف تؤثر على مح حدفات السخيرات
الانباء الوارده من مدينه السخيرات
المغربيه تشير الى ان اطراف الصراع الليبي
على وشك التوصل الى اتفاق في ظل حوار يوصف
بمفاوضات المرحله الحاسمه او الفرصه
الاخيره الترقب يسود الموقف بعد ان تلقى
مبعوت الامم المتحده الخاص بالشان الليبي
تلقى ملاحظات المفاوضين على مقترحاته بشان
شكل المرحله الانتقاليه وبشان صلاحيات
مختلف
المؤسسات لكن صوتا اخر يبدو انه يصر على
ان يبقى هو الاعلى على الساحه الليبيه هو
صوت معارك تدور في وسط العاصمه ومحاوله من
قوات المواليه للواء المتقاعد خليفه حفتر
المؤيد او المؤيد من قبل البرلمان المنحل
في طبرق محاولته التوغل في طرابلس من جهه
العزيزيه جنوب
وذلك ما سنتابع في هذا التقرير لزميلنا
زياد بركات ثم نبدا النقاش مع
ضيوفنا قبيل بدء حوار الصخيرات وفي اثنائه
ثمه حوار بادوات خشنه تديره جماعه حفتر
على الارض بدات بقصف مطار معيتيقه بينما
وفد خصومهم من جماعه المؤتمر العام يتهيا
للسفر ووصلته مقتربه من طرابلس في منطقه
جرا شرقي العاصمه ولاحقا في وسطها في
منطقه فشلوم دارت معارك قد تكون صغيره
لكنها شرسه والاهم انها بالغه رمزيه فان
تضع قدمك على اطراف طرابلس او داخلها يعني
فرض وقائع جديده على الارض وذاك من شانه
قلب المعادلات على طاوله المفاوضات
الدائره خارج البلاد تحسم قوات رئاسه
الاركان المعارك هناك لصالحها فتتراجع
جماعه حفتر وقد سعت لتحقيق اختراق كانت
توابعه ستكون زلزاليه لو نجح في الصخيرات
حيث الجوله الجديده من الحوار هنا تم
الاتفاق بين الفرقاء على تشكيل حكومه وحده
وطنيه لكن المفاوضات دخلت عنق الزجاجه
فالخلافات عاصفه على ما هو اهم السلطه
التشريعيه التي تمنح الشرعيه نفسها
وتتنازع ذلك جهتان المؤتمر الني العام
والبرلماني المجتمعون في طبرق ومما تسرب
فان وفد جماعه المؤتمر يؤيد توسيع الاطار
البرلماني ليشمل طرفي الصراع اي تجاوز
ثنائيه البرلمانيه في طبرق وطرابلس بصيغه
جديده تضمه ما وباقي المكونات الليبيه في
المقابل يصر الطرف الاخر على ان البرلمان
المجتمع في طبرق هو الذي يمنح الشرعيات
للحكومه وبقيه المؤسسات فهو في رايهم
منتخب ويحظى باعتراف دولي وهو ما لم يمر
من دون تشكيك فهو ايضا بلا شرعيه دستوريه
بعد ان قررت المحكمه العليا في البلاد حله
ولا شرعيه لكل ما ترتب عليه من قرارات
ومؤسسات تلك هي المعضله التي قد تغلب خيار
التمديد فيما يسعى حفتر وفقا لخصومه الى
تصعيد ميداني وتفاوض لكسب الوقت والارض
معا مسن بتحالفات اقليميه تدفع في هذا
الاتجاه قد يحدث هذا وقد اصبح خيار التدخل
العسكري الخارجي الذي يريده الرجل ومناصرو
مستبعدا ذاك ما قاله جهرا الرئيس الامريكي
ورئيس الوزراء الايطالي فالحل كما قالاه
في ايدي الليبيين اولا واخيرا وهو ما قد
يزيد الضغط على المتفاوضين لكنه قد يدفع
المتصارعين على الارض احدهما او كلاهما
الى اعتماد سياسه حافه الهاويه فاي اتفاق
قد ينهي ادوار البعض ومنهم حفتر ومن وه
ممن تزايد دورهم بسبب استمرار الصراع
للاقتراب من الحلول
ونشدان للمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
في حلقه اليوم من طرابلس المحلل السياسي
صلاح الشلوي ومن باريس ينضم الينا الكاتب
الصحفي الليبي كامل المرعاش وينضم الينا
من الصخيرات خالد الشكرا استاذ الدراسات
الافريقيه بجامعه محمد السادس نرحب
بضيوفنا من طرابلس باريس والصخيرات وابدا
معك في باريس الاستاذ كامل المرعش نريد في
البدايه تقييما للمرحله التي وصلت اليها
المفاوضات مفاوضات الخرات
برايك حياك الله وكل
المشاهدين الحقيقه بعد ان كان هناك تفاؤل
كبير لدى كل
الليبيين بنتيجه طيبه لهذا الحوار
[موسيقى]
الماراثونية مربع الاول وهو مساله الشرعيه
بعد ان اعتقدنا ان مساله الشرعيه حسمت
وانتقلنا الى تشكيل حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
وربما جسم رئاسي تنفيذي اخر يتفق عليه من
قبل الطرفين لكن ما رشح من الخرات لا ينبئ
بذلك مازالت هناك عيون الميليشيات الشاخص
في الصخرات والتي ترا ق وفد المؤتمر
الوطني العام في شكل مستشارين
وغيره ترفض كل تنازل في هذه المساله و
يعني وفد المؤتمر الوطني العام لا حل بيده
لانه
يخشى الايادي الباطش التي مازالت تحكم
طرابلس والتي ما زالت تصر
كماه خ اليومين الماضيين وهذا اليوم هل
هه في مظاهر قتل في فشلوم قتل المدنيين في
فشلوم و يعني جنوحها الى القوه والسلاح
والقتل طيب لناخذ راي صلاح شلوي هل هل
المشهد بهذه الصوره
ترى لا قطعا هذا مشهد اول مره مساء الخير
تحيه لك ولضيوفك ولجمهور الشاشه اهلا
المشهد هذا الذي تفضل به الزميل من باريس
ربما يكون مشهد ولكنه خيالي ولا يمثل
الواقع الليبي بحال فشلوم مفتوحه امام
وسائل الاعلام مفتوحه وامام مؤسسات
المجتمع المدني مفتوحه امام الامني
انترناشنال مفتوحه امام كل اللجان
الحقوقيه لتدخل وترى طبيعه ما حدث هناك
فشلوم ليست معركه فشلوم قوات التابعه
لوزاره الداخليه دخلت وواجهت بارونات
العصابات المنظمه لا يمكن ان يكون مدنيين
وبيوتهم ترسانات من الاسلحه والذخائر
والمخدرات هؤ هذا بعيد كل ال بعد وكل
الدول تتعامل مع مثل هذه البؤر بشكل حاسم
ولا يمكن ان يسمح طيب في وسط العاصمه ان
تكون هناك بؤر لبارونات بالنسبه لمفاوضات
سخرا المفاوضات مستمره
و المفاوضات مستمره وانا استبعد ان يكون
بين الليبيين شيء اسمه الح الفرصه الاخيره
نحن سنجلس مع بعضنا البعض نحن ليبيين
جميعا مهما اختلفنا نحن ليبيين جميعا ولا
بد ان نبحث لنا عن حل سياسي مهما
كانت شده الخلاف ولكن في نهايه المطاف
سنصل الى حل سياسي يتوافق عليه كل الاطراف
ان شاء الله باي شكل يعني طالت طالت
مده يعني حتى الان استعصى هذا الحل
السياسي الذي تتحدث
عنه كل الدول التي مرت بما مرينا به سيدتي
الكريمه استغرقت عشرات السنوات مثال على
جنوب افريقيا متى بدا الحل السياسي في
جنوب افريقيا بدا في السبعينات ونهايته في
2001 يعني هذه صراعات معروفه حدتها بش يتم
استيعابها
وحلحلة يعني يعتبر
ماذا تفضل طيب خال شكراوي لا يعتبر انه
تاخر الحل مازلنا مازلنا في المرحله
الجنينيه للحل السياسي والحديث عن انها
اخر فرصه ربما اخر فرصه بالنسبه للسيد
ليون لان زمن وظيفته او ولايته محدود ولكن
نحن شعب باقي مع بعضنا البعض هنا وسنجد حل
بدون شك خالد شكراوي اين تكمن العقده
برايك في الحقيقه يعني انا اولا يجب ان
اقول بانه يجب ان نتفاءل ولا يجب ان يعني
ان نقول بان هذا الامر اضحى صعب المنال ان
يصل الليبيون الى نتائج فقط حضورهم هنا
ونقاشاتهم فيما بينهم مع الوسيط الاممي
والحوارات التي سبقت ذلك سواء في جنيف او
في غدامس او في الجزائر ونحن في الجوله
الرابعه في السخيرات كلها اشياء ايجابيه
يجب اعطاء الوقت للوقت ايضا حتى نصل الى
نتيجه العقده المطروحه حاليا ان هناك بعض
الاتفاقات حصلت على على مستقبل ليبيا على
اساس انشاء مجلس رئاسي على اساس تكوين
حكومه
انتقاليه نوعا ما في توصيف بعض الشخصيات
المشكل الذي بقي مطروحا هو المشكل القضيه
التشريعيه والعلاقه فيما بين البرلمانين
سواء برلمان طبرق او المجلس الوطني في
طرابلس وبالتالي لابد من حصول مجموعه من
التنازلات من هذا الطرف وذلك اعتقد باننا
في اطار هته المفاوضات كل طرف يحاول ان
يفرض موقفه وهذا الموقف يطرح على مستويين
المستوى السياسي انطلاقا من المفاوضات
الداخليه حاليا في الخرات ثم هناك ما يجري
في الواقع وفي الارض الليبيه سواء على
مستوى بعض التجاذبات السياسيه او ايضا على
مستوى التجاذبات العسكريه التي في كثير من
الاحيان قد تشكل عائقا لهذا الصر لكن اقد
بافا اتبس منك انه من اجل ايجاد حل يجب
يجب على كل طرف ان يقدم تنازلات السؤال
للسيد كامل مرعاش هل جماعه طبرق مستعدون
لتقديم
تنازلات واضح ان هناك تعند فيما يتعلق
بالحلول الوسط التي يمكن ان تفضي الى
اقتسام السلطه التشريعيه اليس
كذلك نعم انت تتحدثين عن البرلمان الشرعي
في طبرق البرلمان
البرلمان الشرعي والذي تعترف به كل دول
العالم ولم تعترف به المحكمه الدستوريه
انتهينا من هذه المساله ناقشناها كثيرا
هذه محكمه دستوريه يعني حكمت في ظروف
نعرفها كلنا وحكم المحكمه الدستوريه ليس
فيه اي فقره او كلمه تشير الى
حلر السؤال هو الى مد يمكنهم ان يقدموا
تخدم الحل السياسي نعم نعم نعم هو اكبر
تنازل قدمه البرلمان الشرعي الذي يتواجد
مرحليا في طبرق هو الجلوس مع مؤتمر وطني
صنعته الميليشيات هذا اكبر تنازل يعني قدم
وبالتالي لا نلوم البرلمان الشرعي مساله
الشرعيه لا يملكها حتى النواب الذين
يتواجدون في طبرق مساله الشرعيه يملكها
الشعب الليبي صندوق الاقتراع هو الذي افرز
هذه الشرعيه واي حديث عن ضم اعضاء جدد هذا
يمكن ان يعرض هذه المساله ل الطعن
الدستوري فيها وبالتالي هذا لا
يجوز ماه ماه في النهايه لكل طرف
ميليشياته لا لا يا لا يا سيدتي
الميليشيات التي سيطرت على طرابلس والتي
هي احيت
المؤتمر الوطني العام دون حتى ان تنتظر
حكم المحكمه الدستوريه هذا المؤتمر الذي
اعادت اليه الحياه الميليشيات كان في شهر
9/2014
و
اخرى لحظه في في شهر 9/2014 لحظه خليني
ابين هذه النقطه وحكم المحكمه كان في شهر
نوفمبر 2014 الذين يتكلمون عن احترام حكم
المحكمه كان عليهم ان ينتظروا صدور هذا
الحكم ث بعد ذلك يتكلمون عن يعني سياده
الاحكام
الدستوريه طيب حتى طبعا سا احيل هذه
النقطه الى الاستاذ صلاح الشلوي ليرد
عليها ولكن انت الى الان لم تجب على سؤالي
استاذ كامل المرعاش متى تقدم جماعه طبرق
تنازلات باتجاه خدمه مصلحه ليبيا والشعب
الليبي وايجاد حل سياسي ينهي هذه الازمه
التي تمزق
ليبيا انا قلت لك اكبر تنازل هو الجلوس
معهم ومحاوله ضمهم الى جسم
تنفيذ الصراع في
طرابلس لا لا يعني كيف تقتسم السلطه
التشريعيه لا تقتسم هذه السلطه لانه اذا
اجزنا هذا السؤال علينا ان نعود الى الشعب
الليبي وان نجري انتخابات جديده اذا اذا
اذا ا الراع لم لم توهب من احد اذا لم يكن
هناك قابليه للتنازل لما الذهاب الى
المفاوضات في هذه
الحاله نعم الذهاب للمفاوضات لاتاحه
الفرصه للطرف الاخر للمشاركه في اخراج
ليبيا من هذا
المازق يمكن ان يشاركوا في الحكومه لما لا
يعني وهذا ليس كافي ان يشارك في الحكومه
مثلا طيب استاذ صالح الشلوي ما ردك على
هذا الكلام الجسم الرئاسي
مثلا استاذ صلاح انا اتصور ان هناك
ربما اتصور ان السيد
مرعاش اولا التنازل الذي يتكلم عنه وقد
ويدعي ان برلمان المنحل في طبرق قدمه
بالجلوس على مع المؤتمر البرلمان لم يجلس
رفض الجلوس مع المؤتمر ذهب الى السخيرات
ليقول للسيد اليون نحن شرعيون نحن شرعيين
نحن شرعيين ولم ينبس ببنت شفا غير هذه
الكلمه فالبرلمان اساسا لم يقدم هذا
التنازل الذي يدعيه السيد
المرعاش البرلمان رفض على الرغم ان
المؤتمر الوطني العام والوفد المؤتمر في
السخيرات طلب من السيد ليون ان يستدعي وفد
البرلمان للجلوس المباشر ولكنه قال لهم
اخبرهم ان البرلمان يرفض هذا الجلوس
فالبرلمان لم يجلس سيدتي وكما يدعي السيد
مرعاش من من من باريس هذا اولا ثم ان
البرلمان اساسا كان يدعي انه سيتحكم الى
قرار المحكمه العليا ثم لما صدر هذا ال
هذا القرار رفضه ثم ان البرلمان كان مدعو
قبل قبل حتى محكمه صدور صدور قرار المحكمه
العليا كان كان وجه لها المؤتمر الوطني
على لسان السيد نوري بوسهمين رئيس المؤتمر
وجه له الدعوه الى ضروره الحضور الى
طرابلس لاستلام السلطه بشكل بشكل دستوري
ولكن الاختطاف او عمليه الاختطاف منعت
الاعضاء من ال المجيء واستلام السطه بشكل
الدستور كما نص
ل العقده بالفعل اين تكمن ماذا يريد او
تريد جماعه طرابلس جماعه المؤتمر الوطني
العام ماذا يريدون
بالضبط
اي وفد وفد المؤتمر الوطني العام يدعو الى
حل سياسي فوق
قانوني المجتمع الدولي يقول ان الحل سياسي
وليس قانوني ما دام الحل سياسي وليس
قانوني معنى هذا لابد من تجاوز عقده
الشرعيه صراع الشرعيه تجاوز تجاوزه
المجتمع الدولي وتجاوزه المؤتمر الوطني
طيب سناخذ الان فاصلا قصيرا وسوف نعود بعد
هذا الفاصل لنناقش مغزى استمرار المعارك
في ظل التفاوض وما هو تاثير هذه المعارك
على مسار المفاوضات والمحادثات الجاريه في
مدينه الخرات في المغرب ف لا تذهبوا بعيدا
سوف
نعود
مشاهدينا اهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش افاق حل الازمه الليبيه مع
دخول محادثات الخرات مرحله الحسم على وقع
معاركه وصلت الى وسط طرابلس استاذ خالد
الشكرا دلاله التزامن بين التفاوض من جهه
في صخيرات
وبين الامرار المعارك وصولها الى الى
طرابلس
برايك اعتقد بانه يمكن قراءه ما يحدث
حاليا في ليبيا بالمقارنه مع المفاوضات
الجاريه حاليا في الخيرات من خلال قراءتين
القراءه الاولى ان هناك فعلا نزعه عسكريه
في المجال الليبي ربما هناك دعوه الى طرح
الحل العسكري من جهه ثانيه علما بانه لا
يمكن ابدا لا تكتيكيا ولا استراتيجيا ولا
سياسيا ولا منطقي ان يؤدي الحل العسكري
الى نتيجه في ليبيا بحكم تعادل القوى بحكم
تشتتها بحكم عدم وجود اطار عسكري موحد
ونظامي منتم للدوله قادر على استتباب
الامن وعلى ضمان الانتصار لهذه المجموعه
ضد المجموعه الاخرى القراءه الثانيه وهي
ان هذه المعارك تدخل في نطاق نوع من
التجاذبات الاستراتيجيه والتكتيكيه على
اساس ربح بعض المواقع على مستوى التراب
وبالتالي على المستوى السياسي الداخلي
وبالتالي الانتقال من مواقع الى مواقع قوه
في اطار هته المفاوضات لكن عموما والقراءه
العامه يمكن ان نقول بان هته المعارك كلها
سوف تؤدي الى عرقله وان لم تكن سوف تؤدي
الى المزيد من المشاكل في هذا النطاق على
اساس انه لا يمكن الاستمرار في مفاوضات ما
دام الجانب العسكري لم يحسب في هذا الاطار
اعتقد بان الفرقاء الليبيين سواء طبرق ولا
طرابلس عليهم ان يتفقوا اولا على وقف
لاطلاق النار لان المشكله الموجوده حاليا
ليس هو الصراع فقط فيما بين هذين الطرفين
لان وصولهما الى حل مستقبلي على المستوى
السياسي سوف يواجهه مشكل اخر هو حضور
الدوله الاسلاميه حضور مجموعه من
الجماعات المتطرفه والتي تسيطر على اطارات
كبيره من التراب الليبي والتي سوف تعرقل
اي حل مستقبلي لهذا المجال اضف الى ذلك ان
هناك مشكله كبرى سوف تواجه ليبيا هي ضروره
الحق في الاختلاف بالنسبه للمجتمعات
الليبيه المتعدده والتي لها ثقافات
المتعدده الى غير ذلك كما انه لابد من
ضروره المعالجه الارث التاريخي سواء في
المرحله القذافي او في مرحله ما بعد
القذافي عن طريق نموذج للعداله الانتقاليه
عوض ان ننتقل الى ميادين اخرى للانتقام او
غير ذلك لذلك اعتقد بان التحديات كبيره
امام الليبيين وبالتالي يجب تجاوز هته
المعضله العسكريه للتفاهم حول حل سياسي
قادر على اخ ليبيا من عنق نعم استاذ كامل
مرعاش لا يبدو ان الليبيين فقط ملوا كل ما
يجري في ليبيا و انتظارهم ل الحل الذي طال
يعني هناك ايضا المجتمع الدولي الذي يبدو
انه تدمر
من استمرار الازمه في ظل غياب حل استمعنا
الى تصريحات الرئيس الامريكي باراك اوباما
الذي دعى الى ايجاد حل سياسي للصراع في
ليبيا المبعوث الدولي ايضا برناردينو ليون
قال ان الليبيين يكاد ينفذ صبرهم والمج
المجتمع الدولي معهم ايضا
يعني بدا ينفذ صبر الجميع الى متى
اذا الحقيقه في كلامك صحيح لكن في شقه
الاول وهو ان الليبيون ملوا من هذه
المساله لكن لا اعتقد انه المجتمع الدولي
او حتى الدوله الاقليميه ليبيا ملت بالعكس
على العكس تماما هناك بعض الدول الاقليم
الليبي تريد للازمه الليب ان تستمر وترى
فيها يعني بابا لتصدير مشاكلها الى
الاراضي الليبيه ومحاربه الارهاب في في
داخل الاراضي الليبيه بدلا ان تحاربه في
اراضيها عندما يكون هناك جيش ليبي قوي
يستطيع طرد هذه الجماعات المتطرفه من
ليبيا دعيني اشير فقط الى حديث ضيفك من من
الصخرات الذي قال ليبيا يمكن ان تقع فريسه
للجماعات المتطرفه الارهابيه يا سيدي
ليبيا هي الان فريسه لهذه الجماعات
المتطرف رف والفضل كل الفضل يعود الى
امراء الحرب والميليشيات التي سيطرت على
طرابلس وسيطرت على بعض المدن بدليل ان هذه
الجماعات توجد في مناطق نفود هذه
الميليشيات في درنا وفي بنغازي وفي سرت
وفي صبرات وفي طرابلس هذه هذه المناطق
تخضع لنفوذ ما يسمى بفجر ليبيا وانا
اسميها فجر وشروق ارهاب ليبيا لان هي التي
احتضنتها وفي ساعه معينه ردت عليها في سرت
وها نحن نشهد الان هي تقاتل هذه المنظمات
واخرها داعش في سرت اذا ليبيا الان في في
في
الاج نعم صلاح شلوي هذا الخطر خطر
الجماعات المتطرفه الذي جاء اليزيد الطين
بلا الا يفترض ان يسرع في ايجاد
الحل هو للاسف الشديد ان عندما بدا الضابط
المتقاعد خليفه حفتر تمرده في المسمى
بالكرامه كان قبل تكليفه ايضا من البرلمان
وكان يومها مطلوب من السيد عبد الله الثني
وقام بتصفيه الضباط المخالفين له في الراي
والان قبض على عز الدين الوكواك والمجموعه
التي قامت كانت تقوم معه بتصفيه الضباط
وتبين ان هناك يد لخليفه حفتر في تصفيه من
خالفوه من
الضباط الجيش الليبي وا واستعملت اي اله
الاعلام للثوره المضاده لتجريم وشيطنته
فهذا طبعا خلط الاوراق وابرز على الساحه
عده لاعبين بسبب الفوضه التي خلقها خليفه
حفتر واليوم صرنا نواجه صرنا نواجه
الانقلاب الذي يقوده خليفه حفتر في نفس
الوقت نواجه خطر تنظيم الدوله وتنظيم
الدوله يقوم ب يقوم بعمليات انتحاريه ضد
قوات التابعه لل لقيا ل
هيئه قياده الاركان التابعه للمؤتمر
الوطني العام وليس لديهم الى الان معارك
ضد خليفه حفتر وخليفه حفتر عندما يقوم
بضرب القوات التابعه لهيئه الاركان هو
يسهم في اضعاف معركه هذه القوات ضد
الارهاب والتطرف لكن على كل حال المجتمع
الدولي صار يدرك اليوم ان قوات فجر ليبيا
تواجه الارهاب وهي ليست ارهابيه كما يحاول
البعض تسويقها وم لكن دعيني اشير الى شيء
اخر مهم وهو ان مهما كانت كلفه الصراع
السياسي فان في طرف البرلمان في
طرف المؤتمر الوطني العام مازالوا مصرين
ان الحل سياسي وما يقوم به القوات التابعه
سواء لوزاره الداخليه في فشلوم او هو
لمجرد القضاء على بؤر البار
بارونات المخدرات والعصابات المنظمه شكرا
شكرا لك صلاح الشلوي المحلل السياسي
الليبي كنت معنا من طرابلس ونشكر ضيفنا من
باريس ايضا الاستاذ كامل المرعاش الكاتب
والصحفي الليبي ونشكر ضيفنا من السخيرات
خالد الشكرا استاذ الدراسات الافريقيه
بجامعه محمد السادس بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه
من برنامج مورا الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى
والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ا